today the Matt wall show the by the
administration invited a bunch of
groomer drag queens to a rainbow-colored
White House for a celebration of a bill
codifying same-sex marriage and
initiating a full-on assault of
religious liberty in the country uh they
could not be more clear about their
intention at this point also a Human
Rights Campaign report links me to quote
anti-lgbt violence a reporter asked for
my comment about this and I will happily
give it to him but he probably won't
like it plus a trans activist is
gloriously exposed as a shill and a
hypocrite during a house hearing CNN
starts pushing masks again for the
holiday season in our daily cancellation
a washed up comedian embarks on a new
and likely more profitable career as a
fake racism victim all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thing I've learned after many
Christmases with my wife it's that you
can never go wrong with soft cozy gifts
and there's no better place to find such
a gift than cozy Earth cozy Earth is
your One-Stop shop for all things cozy
this holiday season the luxury bedding
is made using the finest premium viscose
from highly sustainable bamboo plus it's
naturally temperature regulating for
both hot and cold sleepers the luxurious
loungewear collection is designed to
flatter everybody type shop their Ultra
Soft lounge pants tees and pajamas for
women or their joggers pullover Crews
and hoodies for men their premium plush
and Waffle bath towels make a uh a great
gift and you know I've already got this
right I got it ready for my wife as a
Christmas gift so she hasn't tried it
yet but she will soon unless she hears
this another surprise will be ruined my
listeners can save 40 now on cozy Earth
bedding loungewear pajamas and towels
but you have to act fast because this
special holiday offer ends soon go to
cozyearth.com Walsh and be sure to enter
Walsh at checkout to save 40 That's
cozyearth.com
it was a patriotic display last night
the White House was a glow lit up in the
colors of the national flag no it wasn't
shining red white and blue of course
those are the colors of the American
flag but that is not the nation that
this Administration represents instead
it was glowing in the various shades of
the rainbow the Gay Pride flag the flag
of LGBT a stand the U.S of gay the only
country that Joe Biden actually cares to
lead and it was a fitting end to a day
that began with an enormous celebration
around the signing of the so-called
respect for Marriage Act a law that
respects marriage about as much as
planned parenthood plans Parenthood as
we've covered on the show the
legislation will codify the radical
leftist redefinition of marriage the
federal level a redefinition of marriage
is actually just the destruction of
marriage it's a redefinition that uh
that gets rid of the quote Old
definition and substitutes it for
nothing which is always how the leftist
redefinition process works and it sets
the stage for
uh for these full-on assault of
religious liberty uh which will
eventually culminate in the
criminalization of any religion that
still adheres to what we now call
traditional beliefs about marriage now
obviously that is not all explicitly
spelled out in the law but it doesn't
need to be
now of course it was less than 20 years
ago that Joe Biden nearly 60 years old
at the time sat on Meet the Press and
firmly declared that marriage is between
a man and a woman
Let's uh relive that moment together
shall we
president used his radio address
yesterday and tomorrow in the Rose
Garden to talk about a constitutional
amendment to ban gay marriage
you know think about this
the world's going to Hades in a
handbasket
we are desperately concerned about the
circumstance relating to uh avian flu we
don't have enough vaccines we don't have
enough police officers and we're going
to debate the next three weeks I'm told
gay marriage a flag Amendment and God
only knows what else I can't believe the
American people can't see through this
we already have a law the Defense of
Marriage Act we've all voted not or I
voted another said look marriage is
between a man and a woman and states
must respect that
nobody's violated that law there's been
no challenge of that law why do we need
a constitutional amendment marriage is
between a man and a woman what's the
game going on here
now Joe Biden had lived 60 years
allegedly believing that marriage was a
man woman Union by definition
a couple years after that interview he
changed his mind
and he happened to change it at exactly
the moment that nearly every other
mainstream Democrat to include Obama
changed theirs also it was a mass
Awakening of sorts all of them together
nearly overnight decided that everything
they'd ever said or supposedly believed
about marriage was wrong
and the one thing that none of them have
ever been able to do is explain why this
change occurred what did they come to
realize about marriage that they hadn't
realized before what convinced them that
their previous ideas were incorrect what
did the LGBT God say to them when it
appeared in a ray of light on the road
to Damascus and sparked their sudden
conversion none of this has ever been
explained
at least not explained by then in an
honest and believed boy
so fast forward a few years and the
White House is now codifying a type of
marriage that Joe Biden of 2006 said
could not by definition even exist
as for the event to start things off
washed up pop singer Sydney Lopper
addressed reporters and thanked Joe
Biden for giving her the permission that
she needs to love who she loves
we can rest easy tonight because our
families are validated and because now
we're allowed to love who we love which
sounds odd to say
but Americans can now love who we love
and
bless Joe Biden and all the people that
worked on this for allowing people not
to worry and their children not to worry
about their future
now it comes as news to most of us that
prior to yesterday afternoon we were
only allowed to love certain people and
now thanks to legislation we can love
anyone we want all of those laws
preventing us from loving people have
been abolished you know all those
anti-love lit bills all of that love
regulation
that's all gone
never mind the fact that it didn't exist
and certainly didn't exist two days ago
so there was a lot of that sort of thing
at the signing event lashing out against
non-existent threats and enemies Joe
Biden delivered his own variation on
this theme
Justice Thomas wondering if even further
and he wrote The Following quote
we should reconsider all the Court's
substantive due process presidents
including Griswold Lawrence
a burgerfuel that means he thinks we
should reconsider whether you've got the
right access to consent to cut to
contraception and yes we should
reconsider whether you have the right to
marry who you love
and that's not only the challenge ahead
when a person can be married in the
morning and thrown out of a restaurant
for being gay in the afternoon this is
still wrong
yeah well that uh isn't happening at all
but don't let that stop you isn't
happening hasn't happened wouldn't
happen
literally just is not happening at all
nobody's getting thrown out of a
restaurant for being gay
okay that's not that's not happening
anywhere there's not anywhere where the
owner of restaurants going up to someone
say hey I heard you're gay get out of
here we don't serve your kind here get
out
just literally not happening period
which isn't to say that nobody's getting
thrown out of restaurants for who they
are or what they believe in fact just
last week a Christian group was denied
service and kicked out of a Virginia
restaurant for that reason because of
what they believed and who they were
Christians
there's no dispute about the facts of
that case the restaurant owner proudly
admits to it
but Joe Biden isn't worried about that
sort of discrimination on the contrary
the objective is to exactly create a
culture of that sort of hostility
towards Christians and other Outsider
groups
but Biden didn't just use the
opportunity to invent wild stories about
forms of discrimination that no gay
person in the country has ever or will
ever face
he branched out and began Shilling also
for child mutilation and castration
listen
s what hospitals libraries and community
centers are threatened and intimidated
excuse me because they support
lgbtq Children and Families we have to
speak out
we must stop the hate and violence like
we just saw in Colorado Springs we're a
place of acceptance and celebration
targeted for violence and Terror
we need to challenge the hundreds of
callous cynical laws introduced in the
states targeting transgender children
terrifying families and criminalizing
doctors who get children the care they
need we have to protect these children
so they know they are loved and we will
stand up for them and say I can seek for
themselves
so the president of the United States
demented old pervert that he is wants to
protect these children by ensuring that
they are sexually abused and chemically
castrated this is not only horrifying
and deranged in its own right it also
may come as a surprise to the more you
know oblivious sorts of conservatives
who thought that the gay marriage bill
was just about gay marriage
the people in this naive category may
have also been shocked by the guest list
for this event
Biden sent out invitations to all sorts
of various Freaks and Weirdos such as a
drag queen who goes by the name Marty
Cummings and um though Marty is an
explicitly sexual performer he often
performs for children including
children's youngest two years old in at
least one case with that in mind it's no
surprise that Kamala Harris kicked
things off by paying homage to the great
Harvey Milk
and as the great Harvey Milk once said
I quote
rights are one only by those who make
their voices heard
[Applause]
and because you made your voices heard
marriages are more secure and Joe Biden
is our president
[Applause]
now Harvey Milk had a habit of sexually
abusing drug-addicted teenage boys this
is what qualifies you for greatness in
the eyes of the modern Democrat Party so
to review
Biden held an event to sign a bill
codifying gay marriage on the federal
level to which he invited drag queens
who perform for children and during the
event he shield for child castration
while his vice president hailed a
notorious sexual abuser
that kind of summarizes it
so I must ask then the conservatives
quote unquote who supported this bill
which there are many
uh many Republicans support it's the
only way that it was passed
and many other conservatives have come
out in support of it or said that
they're okay with it
I must ask those conservatives or or any
who support you know the Democratic view
of marriage as an institution in general
of them I must ask do you people
understand
what is going on now
do you Patsy's get it yet has it sunken
in will it ever
is this enough
they are shouting their real agenda into
a megaphone under a rainbow Spotlight
with half-naked drag queens dancing all
around is that enough for you to notice
is it still too subtle are you still
sitting there like I don't understand I
don't know what's going on here can you
hear them yet
they're not whispering
do you understand that the Democrats are
not actually interested in protecting
anyone's right to love a right that was
never under threat and couldn't be
because it wouldn't be possible to pass
a law Banning love even if we wanted to
do you understand that these people are
actually interested in destroying
everything that is good and true and
beautiful and real in our culture that
they want to demolish literally every
pillar of human civilization that they
reject every Insight passed to us from
our ancestors and they are in the
process of fundamentally reshaping this
country into a nihilistic sexually
debased Wasteland of misery and moral
Anarchy is that clear yet to you
everything they are doing is to that end
it is all for that purpose
can you see that yet
how many drag queen pedophiles and BDSM
dog fetishes do they have to pack into
the rainbow before you wake up
well imagine if you aren't awake yet
you never will be
so be it
then just stay in your stupor
but get the hell out of the way
and let the rest of us fight this fight
the way it needs to be fought
and do what needs to be done
now let's get to our five headlines
man do you think it's time to stop
mindlessly scrolling time to finally
gain that higher quality of life you
know you're missing out on if this
sounds familiar then on January 9th join
thousands of men all over the world to
embark on a 90-day journey together in
search of a better life it's called
Exodus 90 and it was built to help men
enjoy the freedom of becoming who they
are and who they were truly made to be
xs90 guides you and removing the
attachments that are holding you back
from a better life and it actually works
independent research shows that it's
Exodus 90 and the men who participate
report considerable shifts after the 90
days including stronger satisfaction
rates in their marriages more meaningful
prayer lives and dramatic decreases in
time spent on their phones for the past
seven years Exodus has helped more than
sixty thousand men build a road map for
living with virtue in a culture that
offers far too many paths to
self-destruction so is it time for your
Exodus we start January 9th find
resources to prepare for Exodus at
exodus90.com Walsh that's
exodus90.com Welsh
the Human Rights Campaign apparently put
out a report couple of days ago titled
online harassment offline violence
unchecked harassment of gender affirming
care providers in children's hospitals
and social media and its offline violent
consequences
is the report they published and it
outlines the ways that conservative
media primarily myself and live with
Tick Tock have fomented violence
allegedly against LGBT people and when I
say it outlines the way that we've done
this I mean that it invents this story
fleshes out this narrative uh out of
whole cloth So reading from the top of
the report
and this goes on for pages and Pages uh
but it says anti-equality online
extremists are leading a proactive and
coordinated campaign of hate against
hospitals and medical providers who
offer gender affirming care for
transgender non-binary and questioning
youth social media posts from accounts
like Libs of tick tock and Matt Walsh
kick off a cycle of harassment and
stigma with the ultimate goal of
inciting violence and shutting down
access to life-saving and medically
necessary gender affirming care hate
speech accounts post an inflammatory
message full of disinformation about
gender affirming care and call out a
specific hospital or doctor by name the
doctrine Hospital almost immediately
begins receiving a barrage of harassing
and threatening messages online offline
doctors and hospitals named in social
media harassment campaigns face
harassment and threats at their homes
and workplaces in the most extreme
examples doctors face death threats and
hospitals face bomb threats halting care
for all patients it extremist
politicians looking to rile up the most
extreme members of their base join in
spreading the same transphobic rhetoric
from their platforms in some cases going
so far as to introduce legislation to
regulate children's hospitals and gender
affirming care providers hospitals halt
gender affirming care services or remove
online resources and websites in order
to protect the safety of their patients
and staff so that's that's uh the human
resources or the Human Rights Campaign
uh
going through this uh this how the
process as it plays out that they're
inventing now not all of this is
invented
um so some of this is actually true not
much of it but some of it is like for
example
um stigma yeah I fully admit 100 you can
quote me on this Human Rights Campaign
quote me on it I am trying to stigmatize
doctors and hospitals and so-called
health care providers who abuse children
I am absolutely trying to stigmatize
them I want there to be a very very
harsh stigma around that
I want all forms of child abuse to be
stigmatized
at a minimum
um
so you're right about that
the part you're wrong about
is that we have called for or encouraged
violence and that's why in this report
that again goes on for pages and Pages
there is not one example provided there
never is any example provided of any of
us ever encouraging violence at all
there are no actual examples because
we've never done it
and yet we are accused of encouraging
violence even as this lengthy War and
Peace length report cannot give any
examples of what it accuses us of
now I found out about this uh about this
report because a reporter named Benjamin
Ryan tweeted at me looking for comments
and this is I didn't even know that this
was uh being done and he tweeted he said
hi Matt today the Human Rights Campaign
released a report tying your rhetoric
with regards to lgbtq issues with
anti-lgbtq violence how do you respond
to that
and I gave him my statement I said hi
Ben my official statement in response is
that the Human Rights Campaign is a far
left extremist organization full of
hacks and frauds and I couldn't give
less of a damn what they say anyone who
takes them seriously is dumber than a
pile of bricks yourself included thanks
that was my official statement but that
I hope he includes in its totality in in
whatever piece of propaganda he's
writing for the New York Times or
whatever he's writing for and if I could
just elaborate a bit on that I think I
don't think I need to elaborate much
because I've that's I said what I had to
say
but if I were to elaborate I would only
say that
the ability of the Human Rights Campaign
or of Benjamin himself or anyone in the
media
to control me
uh depends on my
consent my participation like I always
say about cancel culture you know you
have to in many cases participate in
some way in your own cancellation and
it's the same sort of thing here I would
have to participate in my own emotional
blackmail
by deciding to care what these people
think that's the participation that is
required of me
the only way the Human Rights Campaign
can like scare me or make me or cause me
to fall into Silence by publishing a big
report Matt Walsh encourages violence
only way they could do that is if I care
what they think
but the problem that Ben runs into and
that the uh the Human Rights Campaign
runs into and that Media Matters runs
into is that I don't care at all
I just don't you know Media Matters and
I found out about this
um
because it was tweeted at me one of our
friends at the of the daily wire Margot
tweeted this to me that uh apparently
and this is true I I checked it if you
Google unless they've taken it down now
but if you Google on your phone Media
Matters
and it pops up they act you'll see that
they have a whole category on their
website
for me
so they've got these broad categories of
subjects and then they've just got a
whole other thing which is Matt Walsh
now you can click on that and you can
see that's like three or four times a
week they're posting articles
um
but it's very frustrating for them
because what they find again is that I
just don't care I don't care what you
think about me your approval doesn't
matter to me
in fact it's worse than that for them
um
it's it's I don't care about their
approval I'm not trying to get their
approval
but as for their opinion in general
whether it's Human Rights Campaign or
this reporter or Media Matters I do
actually care about their opinions sort
of because I want them to hate me
I do because they are contemptible and
Despicable
and I would feel deeply ashamed of
myself if they didn't hate me
so
when they tell me that they hate me and
they insult me and they accuse me of
things that only makes me feel more
confident and reassured
now that's not that the the the number
one thing driving me is that I want to
be hated by these people
but I do consider that a sign that I'm
doing the right thing
in fact honestly if I go if I go a few
weeks and there's not some hit piece
being published About Me by someone I
start to think man I must be I must be
slipping I'm I'm falling off here
I'm not doing my job
so that's the issue
and you can put all that in your article
too if you want
um all right this is a great clip here I
I uh so we've done some some kind of
heavy and and dark subjects uh but but
this I love this is the house oversight
and reform committee that a hearing on
quote the evolution of anti-democratic
extremist groups and the ongoing threat
to democracy this was supposed to be it
was designed to be of course an
opportunity to defame conservatives but
representative Nancy mace
flip the script now I'm no Nancy May's
fan
to put up mildly she's one of the
Republicans who signed on for this uh
for this so-called respect Marriage Act
and you know so I'm I'm not a fan of
hers she's generally a left-leaning
republican who goes along with the
Democrats agenda on so many issues
but credit where it's due she shined in
this moment this was a great moment this
was her greatest moment against one of
the most vile and disgusting trans
activists in the country
um this is because they got a bunch of
activists that they brought in
and one of them is uh Alejandra carabao
who's a male who identifies as a female
and is an absolute soulless ghoul of a
human being
just an awful awful person
now of course that describes all trans
activists I mean all trans activists are
reprehensible
goblins
they are I mean these are these are the
the most vicious reprehensible people in
the political sphere period
every single one without exception but
this one in particular so let's watch as
this kind of a long clip and we'll we'll
kind of follow along uh and we start by
Nancy mace
baiting the Trap so here we go
is rhetoric on social media a problem
and a threat to our democracy Mr Ward
yes absolutely Mr Siegel yes Miss
carabayo yes Ms Normani yes Miss Tyler
yes
yes
um another question I have uh do you
believe that rhetoric targeting
officials with violence for carrying out
their constitutional duties
um is a threat to democracy Mr Ward
Mr seagull
yes
yes
yes
yes
all right thank you very much only a few
weeks after the attempted attack on a
Supreme Court Justice on June 25th one
of the witnesses Alejandra carabayo
tweeted out the following in response to
a decision on abortion overturning Roe v
Wade and I'll quote directly from the
Tweet the six justices who overturned
ROE should never know peace again it is
our civic duty to accost them every time
they're in public they are pariahs since
women don't have their rights these
justices should never have a peaceful
moment in public again I know something
about being accosted the night of
January 5th I was physically accosted on
the streets of DC in Navy yard by a
constituent of mine I fervently blamed
rhetoric rhetoric on social media
rhetoric at public events for being
physically accosted I carry a gun
everywhere I go when I am in my district
and I'm at home because I know purse
personally that rhetoric has
consequences I've had my car key I've
had my house spray painted I had someone
trespassed in my house as recently as
August I've been doxed on social media
about where I live and I've had to add
to security everywhere I go often
because I can't afford it I have to
carry my own firearm wherever I go and
Alejandra carabayo also recently tweeted
on November 19th not even a month ago
that the Supreme Court vested with the
judicial power of the United States by
our Constitution stated they are not a
legitimate Court issuing decisions and
also the Supreme Court is an organ of
the far right so my last question today
of Ms carabayo do you stand by these
comments this kind of rhetoric on social
media
and do you believe it's a threat to
democracy
thank you representative for the
opportunity to clarify and provide
context to my tweets
um I have a question is it yes you know
do you believe your rhetoric is a threat
to democracy when you're calling to a
cost a branch of government the Supreme
Court
I don't believe that's a correct uh
characterization statements did you not
tweet that that you thought that the
Supreme Court Justices should be
accosted
characterization of my statements
uh that's great and what makes it great
too is that we've got carabaio saying
that's not that's an unfair
characterization of my statements
meanwhile his statements are right
behind her right there you can see it
you said you wanted a cost I had to say
that that's not what I said it's right
there
now
others is a beautiful moment uh because
it exposes
the uh of course the hypocrisy and the
double standards and everything and and
but more than that it just exposes
the the hollowness of what these people
say
and that that's really the value
because pointing out double standards it
only goes so far I get that
the value in doing it is that
it shows it demonstrates
um that what these people say is it's
totally Hollow nothing that they say
means anything it doesn't mean anything
all they care about is themselves they
are utterly consumed and this is the
case of leftist activists in general in
particular trans activists they are just
totally consumed by their own ego it's
the only thing they care about that's it
and so they're going and they want all
of society to revolve around them and to
affirm everything they believe about
themselves and to participate in
whatever delusional uh you know charade
that they demand and they're just gonna
say whatever they feel like they need to
say to to advance that agenda doesn't
mean anything
there are no principles here there are
no there are no underlying principles
I wish that was the case
you know the people that talk about uh
when you say make these statements it's
a threat to democracy and all this like
I and we used to call these people
always the lefties are there snowflakes
and they're oversensitive and there's
still people on the right who say that
but that that was never the case I wish
it was that I wish it was just that I
wish it was uh the problem people on the
left is that someone like carabaio
the problem with these people is that
they're overly sensitive and you know
they take words too seriously and uh you
know and they have this almost like
Victorian prudishness when it comes to
language I wish that was the case
you know I know people who are actually
overly sensitive
and that could it could be a bad thing
it could be a flaw
but it does emanate from it's it's a
sensitivity like you you care about
people that's what I mean if you're
actually sensitive it means you're a
sensitive and caring person
it's not bad to be a sensitive and
caring person I'm not but it's not bad
to be that
and yeah it can go a little bit too far
sometimes and uh and all of that but
that's not the issue here this is not
about sensitivity this is not about
thinking you know they they want
civility in language
now the real answer that carbio is not
going to give and didn't give there
is that
well no it's okay to call for a costing
Supreme Court Justice because they
deserve to die
like he wants them dead that's it
actually wants them dead
these people they would be happy
if someone actually made into Brett
Kavanaugh's house the guy who came to
kill if he actually made it into the
house and and murdered him and his whole
family they would be happy they would be
they would be ecstatic
so that's the answer
they deserve to die
anyone who disagrees with them deserves
to die that is their actual belief
all right and another clip here
changing subjects a bit CNN is uh
pushing masks again as we get into the
holiday we're hearing more about uh
maybe we need to get back into masking
and let's watch this
New York officials are now urging people
to start wearing masks up again since
we've seen an uptick in cases and we're
seeing a rise in flu cases as well and
hospitals that are starting to get uh
more busy and busier through this
holiday season do you think that
Americans and New Yorkers will start
putting their masks on though after they
haven't for so many months
yeah I I think so I think the framework
though has to be one of individual
protection so I was rounding in the
hospital today seeing patients and I saw
multiple coveted patients multiple flu
patients even someone with something
called metanumovirus which is another
respiratory infection that travels
around this time of year and I think as
people see just how much virus there is
out there this time of year you know
when you're in a public place and you're
surrounded by strangers throwing on a
mask for you know 30 minutes while you
go shopping is not too much to ask just
to protect yourself even if you're a
healthy person you know being sick for a
week or two with flu or covid is not fun
no it's not but I have to tell you just
from watching people here in the city I
don't see many people walking around in
masks yet now that could change in the
next few weeks while we have you let me
ask you about another alarming
development that we've seen and that's a
shortage of over-the-counter medications
and these are medications that are
prescribed for fever reduction and pain
typically given to Children we've seen
an increase in in covid flu RSV how
alarming is that and what can parents do
do now
so many kids are sick I've got three of
them um they've all had their share of
respiratory illnesses this season
it doesn't it's no big deal it's not not
too much to ask to throw the mask on uh
is they're gonna try to ramp up the
masking again and well it is it is too
much to ask you actually it's way too
much
um if you're asking me to throw the mask
on for 30 minutes you're asking me for
30 minutes too many uh of wearing the
mask I do want to make one point about
this mask thing though enough has been
said about it I think you all know my
view on the subject of masking but
one thing that frustrates me slightly
when we talk about masks
is when the anti-masks are Masters
such as myself otherwise known as just
like Common Sense regular people
uh when they frame their arguments
around the claim
that the masks don't work
right they say oh the map still works so
why should we wear them
and it's true of course that so many of
the masks that people have been wearing
in the context in which they've worn
them have been
statistically close to useless or worse
I mean even the so-called experts will
now admit that the cloth masks you know
uh they're not doing much for covid and
certainly you know back when like people
were wearing it's like wearing bandanas
and all this stuff it's like in the
early days they would just put something
on your face it doesn't matter what it
is like that's not doing anything
um and and they'll also admit that most
people were never wearing the masks
properly or wearing clean ones and so
the whole thing was just a pointless
charade
but that's not really my issue with the
mask and I I think it's a
we make a mistake by making that the
issue
because I don't care if the masks work
or not I don't care it's that's not the
point that has nothing to do with it for
me at all
I've never been all that interested in
the question of oh do they work how much
they work what are the stats doesn't
matter it makes no difference that is
not that was never in my calculations
like maybe just speaking for myself
when I decided early on I'm not doing
this damn Mass thing it wasn't because I
don't think this works it was just
because I'm just not doing it I don't
care if it works or not it now it's true
that a properly fitting n95 mask if it's
clean if it's worn correctly yeah it'll
help prevent
to some extent the the spread of
different sorts of viruses and pathogens
and all of that there's a reason why you
know doctors and surgeons in hospitals
when the Performing surgeries have
always worn masks like that medical
grade masks and it was it was never an
issue it just it made sense in that
context that it makes sense
um
so when we structure the whole argument
around whether or not they work
then it sounds like we're conceding
that if effective masks could be
disseminated to everybody and if they
were properly worn that maybe we'd be on
board for masking but I'm not conceding
that and I never have and I certainly
don't now so even in a in a fairy tale
magical fairy tale world where everyone
had a top of the line medical grade the
best mask on the market and uh everyone
had like an unlimited supply of them so
they could always have a clean one on
and all of that
which that that world could never exist
but if it did I I wouldn't find that a
magical fairy tale world that would be a
nightmare for me because I don't care if
the masks work I don't care if it
decreases my chances of getting sick or
not I'm sure that if I walked around in
rubber gloves all the time you know and
I I I I always had the the surgical
gloves on and I had a stash of them in
my car that people are actually doing
this during coverage for a while maybe
some people still are like I'm sure if I
did that that that might uh prevent the
spread of certain
viruses might that might prevent me from
getting sick in certain contexts maybe
it might help
not doing it I don't care it doesn't it
I'm not living that way
that's always been my argument and it is
my argument now
I want to breathe fresh air I want to
be able to see people's faces
okay you want to see and be seen in
public that's that's that's that's
that's
part of the value of being out in public
among people it's just a normal human
experience and that's what I want I just
want the normal human experience of
going outside breathing fresh air uh
being able to talk to people and
understand them and see their facial
expressions and so you can have the full
range of human communication okay
because body language and facial
expression is a big part of
communication I want all of that
and I'm willing to accept whatever risks
may come from it yeah going out in
public there are always risks involved
in that and not just covid
first of all there are much more
dangerous viruses than that out there
that you could you could you could pick
up potentially and there's a million
other things that could happen anytime
you walk outside your house I'm willing
to accept all that
that's it
to me that's a stronger argument
although there there is plenty that can
and should be said about the
effectiveness of masks and all that kind
of stuff to me the more the more
unassailable sort of bulletproof
argument is when you don't even give
them that
when you turn into a conversation about
the effectiveness to me that's a losing
argument
better argument is when they say oh
you're taking a risk it's written okay
sure fine that's fine I'm willing to do
that and I don't care
what can you say now
all right uh what else we got here
's a quick uh story this is interesting
because 70 years from Yahoo a 70 year
old school bus attendant was spit on by
a student and the man's response
amounted to felony child abuse according
to the York Poquoson sheriff's office in
Yorktown Virginia
dispute happened on a York County bus as
it was transporting Elementary School
students officials said York county is
about 25 miles north of Norfolk it was
reported that a seven-year-old student
spit on the suspect uh the sheriff said
no news release in turn he sprayed the
student with a cleaning solution
the suspect who lives in York County was
employed as a bus assistant for the York
County School Division at the time he's
no longer working for the district
investigators did not say the student
was injured the type of cleaning fluid
used was not announced the suspect was
arrested December 6th and taken to the
Virginia Peninsula Regional Jail he's
charged with three felony accounts of
malicious bodily injury by means of a of
any caustic substance and one felony
count of abuse and neglect of children
uh
so there's a lot in this story that
we're not told that I think is important
like what is the cleaning was this
bleach or something or was this
something actually go blind the child or
cause serious injury because if that's
the case then obviously yeah you gotta
put the guy in prison for that uh was
this like uh
essentially just a bottle of soap and
water that he had back there he was
cleaning and then the kids spit on him
and just sort of like reflexively the
way you do with a cat you just sprayed
them with the water uh is that what
happened because that to me that would
change things rather significantly but
was there an actual danger of any kind
of physical harm
um
so that I don't know
but to me the bigger point you just hear
these kind of stories and I think back
to when I was on the bus when I was a
kid
and uh you know Elementary School this
was the case especially in Middle School
the bus even when I was going to to
school you know over two decades ago the
bus was uh it was like a war zone it was
just total Anarchy and especially these
poor bus assistants who they I never
could figure out even when I was a kid I
still can't figure out why they put
people in these positions because
usually it's older people you put them
in the back of the bus and they just get
harassed and tormented constantly by the
kids that's the only reason that they're
there apparently just to absorb all that
abuse
and uh I think about witnessing that
when I was a kid
and how much worse it must be now
you know because things have not gotten
better it's not like kids have become
more disciplined over time uh I don't
think parenting has gotten better over
time right generationally
so however bad it was we can assume that
it's even worse now
and although this was not the correct
response obviously
um it does show again like when you have
a seven-year-old he says still young
seven years old seven-year-old spitting
on someone that is that is not normal
seven-year-old Behavior at least it
shouldn't be
that is Way Beyond inappropriate for
that age range
um if I you know I have a six-year-old
and if he went and spit on some adult
Stranger in public I I would be I would
I'd be Beyond Furious also at myself for
failing as a parent
um
and so you just see again the the
impossible situation as critical as I am
of
School staff and teachers and there's
lots of criticism that needs to be
directed in that and it needs to go in
that direction
especially with the grooming and the the
indoctrination that goes on
but at the same time I can recognize
that they're also being put in some
possible situation
um
being you know
in in these environments with with kids
that have not been parented at all
and then increasingly increasingly over
time we also take away their ability to
punish
every every you know
increasingly these these potential
punishments are taken away
um
you know you can't expel kids anymore
all this kind of stuff
so the hands are tied behind their back
there's just nothing they can do
except absorb the abuse
until eventually they've had enough of
it and they freak out and start
spraying cleaning solution all over the
place all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's the blame
it's a sweet baby gang
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you knock out your holiday shopping with
a ton of awesome new products this year
you can shop the best Brewing gear
thermoses mugs and apparel designed for
folks who love country and coffee bike
rifle sources the most exotic Rose from
around the globe all coffee is roasted
here in the US by veteran-led teams of
coffee experts you can stuff your
Christmas stockings with the latest
roast from America's coffee for 10 off
with my code Walsh better yet sign your
Secret Santa up for a coffee Club
subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need the most
it's the gift that keeps on giving Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated they take pride in serving
coffee and culture to people who love
America every purchase we make with
Black Rifle coffee helps support veteran
and first responder causes so go to
Black riflecoffee.com use promo code
walls for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com promo code walls for 10
off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
Mr action production says you did it
boys you made them redefine language to
support their argument that's as close
to an admission of defeat as you can
expect uh yeah it is an admission to
defeat like we talked about yesterday
and that's that's one thing about it any
kind of argument that you're in is um
it's important to know when the argument
is won
and
you know when someone's in a position
where they're changing the dictionary
in order to support their view because
they can't they they have no definition
they can offer for the words they're
using and so they just change the
dictionary to accommodate for that fact
then they just they've lost the argument
they're not going to admit to it people
don't people don't people don't admit
when they've lost arguments especially
when it's an ideological
argument
so I'm not going to admit to it
but they've still lost
Jasmine Houston Burns says quoting me a
part of your job is to not bring your
weariness into your employment Jasmine
says exactly you have to say the same
thing a dozen times a day but that
person in front of you has never heard
it before plus there's a tendency to be
mad when people don't know well you
didn't tell them
yeah this is the challenge it's like
there's a version of this challenge in
any job especially a customer service
job and I can understand talk about
being in a you know being an impossible
situations and all of that I can
understand why people in the service
industry
get frustrated and annoyed I've worked
those jobs in the past I definitely got
frustrated annoyed but but also you just
you just have to remember that this
weariness that you feel you're doing the
same thing over and over and over again
with a million customers well each
customer that's not their experience
and uh
you know they're they're not in there
thinking about the fact that you've
already dealt with a million customers
I think
this is something that
I don't know maybe the TSA could also
keep in mind
and they're I've met some plenty of
friendly TSA agents including recently
it was a TSA agent who's a fan of the
show and stopped me he's a very nice guy
so this does not apply to all of them
but it's like going through the airport
you have these TSA agents who are just
barking orders at people and uh in this
extremely exasperated uh annoyed kind of
way and sometimes you'll even hear them
talking to each other how many times I
got to say it well yeah you've said it a
million times but not but the person
that you're shouting at hasn't heard it
a million times they just walk through
security this is the first time they've
heard it
all right
uh Rose says Matt is groovy way cool
boss based and the bee's knees go sweet
Daddy-O
see there's there's some slang I can I
can uh get with like I said you get
three each generation is allowed to come
up with three new slang words
so this the current the current youngest
generation has already gone way above
their uh allotted amount
uh Aaron says if some creep attacked my
daughter in the Ladies Room he'd soon be
identifying as a paraplegic
this is the question we always have
especially especially with the issue of
men going into women's rooms and and Men
invading
women's teams and everything
one of the big questions is like where
are the fathers in these situations
and sometimes the fathers are there and
they're speaking out
but oftentimes that's a
a very conspicuous silence
that's why I don't
you know there's some conservatives who
will Who will blame the girls who are
not sticking up for themselves and it's
like girls need to speak out the women
on these sports teams they need to speak
out and they do that's true
but
I'm more looking at parents I'm looking
at the men I'm looking at the fathers
why aren't you speaking up in defense of
your your daughters
there are some who are doing that but
not nearly enough
um
and Michael Tyson says maybe the
Christmas tree is putting people in
danger because a live squirrel comes
running out at someone's face like the
Griswolds yeah that could be it you know
I was thinking about this yesterday
because we we had the the story of the
um person with the Human Rights
Commission in whatever state that was I
forget now but she was very very upset
at a Christmas tree in the in the
library she was really angry about it
and uh just cussing people out and all
the rest of it
and she had to resign and that's good
and I said how could anyone get this
angry about a Christmas tree Christmas
tree is a is a site that should bring
joy to anyone should make anyone smile
even me and all that is true but I but I
should allow for the fact this is not
why she was upset about it but I I have
actually
been that angry about a Christmas tree
in the past I mean I I have I have
cussed out Christmas trees I have cussed
out many a Christmas tree in my life I
must admit that although it's a
different kind of situation
because it's like when when it's your
Christmas tree and you're trying to do
the real Christmas tree thing and you're
trying to put it up and uh make it stay
up straight that's when it's okay to get
that angry at a Christmas tree
um
I I've had at least twice where I got so
angry at the Christmas tree I just threw
it outside and we decided to get a fake
one instead
so that's okay but when it's someone
else's Christmas tree
and they've already gone through all
that trouble and they're the ones who
have to water it and all that kind of
stuff and they put the lights on and all
the annoying stuff then there's no
reason to be angry about it that's a
stipulation don't miss out on our last
daily wire backstage of the Year tonight
at 7 pm Eastern 6 p.m Central from the
red wave that wasn't Elon dropping the
Twitter files myself and the rest of the
gang we'll be discussing the most
important stories of the day and the
year witness the festivities and join me
Ben Shapiro Michael Knowles Andrew
Clavin and daily wire god king Jeremy
boring for a very merry backstage you
won't want to miss it so tune in tonight
at uh 6 p.m Central 7 P.M Eastern adds
daily wire
plus.com we will see you there now let's
get to our daily cancellation
foreign
have any exact numbers to flesh this out
but it seems to me that we have reached
another period of peak race hustling of
course the race Hustlers are always out
there skulking and crawling about but
there are seasons when they are less
active and then there are seasons when
they're more active much like deer ticks
or other blood-sucking parasitic life
forms in that ebb and flow cycle it
would appear that we are now in a time
of flow the disingenuous tiers of racial
self victimization are certainly flowing
as furiously as they ever have before
which is why over the past few weeks
when it comes time for the daily
cancellation often the toughest choice
is to decide which which racial
grievance-mongering phony I'll focus on
vote today I think there is one who
really stands out from the rest and that
is Mark Curry Mark Curry is a former 90s
sitcom actor who over the last couple of
decades has fallen into near total
obscurity and he now tours the country
as an alleged comedian searching for the
most undiscerning crowds to perform in
front of he's a struggle to gain
attention or publicity through the
strength of his comedy and I'm assuming
that's why he's decided to
just finally cash in his victim tokens
at the prize counter and take what he
can get for them and he has been able to
get
something he's gotten some headlines out
of it he's gotten some pity he'll
probably get a lawsuit here's the story
from NBC News it says comedian Mark
Curry accused the Colorado Hotel staffer
of racially profiling him as he sat in
the lobby an incident that prompted
outrage from celebrities and a promise
from the establishment to refund him
after the actor posted video of the
alleged encounter on Instagram Curry who
starred in ABC's Hanging with Mr Cooper
from 1992-1997 was staying at the Mining
Exchange in Colorado Springs
he was in the city for performances at
three E's comedy club on Friday and
Saturday uh Curry was drinking coffee
when he said the employee asked him if
he was a guest he also informed him the
lobby was Private the comedian said
according to the video NBC News does not
know what happened before Curry started
recording recording
well of course they don't
because one thing we know about almost
any video relating to a supposed racism
controversy is that the video always
picks up in the middle of the exchange
or the incident we're never told what
happened beforehand
um and before we play some of this out
of context video for you here's the
hotel's response NBC news reports again
we are committed to providing a safe and
inclusive space for all guests and
employees the statement read we deeply
regret this incident and have reached
out to Mr Curry to offer not only our
sincere apologies but a full refund of
his stay and an invitation to return at
no cost any time in the future as a
respected Community partner we are also
using this opportunity to revisit
training with our staff helping to
ensure all interactions are reflective
of our company Windham Hotels and
Resorts issued a similar statement The
Mining Exchange is a Wyndham Hotel quote
the hotel's owner and management team
are working to make this right the
company wrote on Twitter on Sunday
so they deeply regret the incident
and it is indeed regrettable
but not because of the employee's
Behavior
even in spite of the out of context
nature of this video
and the sketchy details about what
exactly precipitated it
we still can clearly identify the bad
guy in this situation
now this goes on for about 25 minutes
but I'll show you about two minutes of
it here's the first two minutes and here
it is
all right so the problem is I'm in a
hotel lobby and this man wants to see
well let me let me see some ID
you got your backup how you doing back
up does he speak
hello back up
John you've been you've been here for 15
minutes
okay we're gonna put you all right
people
he was asking me for my I can't be in
the hotel lobby
this hotel lobby you cannot be in this
hotel lobby if you're black and you're a
Colorado's friend so if you're black and
you're Colorado Springs you can't be in
the lobby wow this is crazy isn't it so
check it out
oh yeah
yeah
look they got a black man in Colorado
Springs so they send this dude look yeah
oh yeah the one he talks now he talks
yeah
yeah so a black man can't be
yeah yeah I'm trying to pull a race car
boy so so so we got an Uncle Tom calling
me saying I'm doing the race car but he
but he hanging with this dude this is
what it's all about people
he called me uh the race car
are you a guest of the hotel I can't
hear you say it again you heard me I
couldn't hear you my hard of hearing
foreign
that continues for 20 more minutes as
Mark Curry the victim quote unquote
becomes more and more belligerent
shouting and cussing at the hotel
employees who are simply trying to do
their jobs Curry posted this video on
Instagram along with the name of one of
the hotel employees and the hotel's
phone number he sent an angry mob after
the establishment many prominent people
joined in the mob celebrities coming to
Curry's defense expressing their support
for him during this difficult and
traumatic time
and yet anybody with ears and a brain to
go between them can watch this and
clearly see that the bad guy in this
scenario is curry himself
I mean how morally deranged do you have
to be as an individual to watch that
and think that the guy holding the
camera is the good guy
in fact Curry's not only the bad guy but
he's also the racist one in the exchange
he repeatedly mocks one of the hotel
workers who's also black calling him an
Uncle Tom making fun of the way he looks
he is screaming racial slurs of the
hotel staff while claiming to be the
rate the racism victim in the
conversation
and all of this simply because he was
asked if he was a guest at the hotel he
could have answered and said yes
and the conversation would have been
over
that's all you had to do
instead he turned this low stakes
totally normal interaction into a
30-minute argument and then turned the
30-minute argument into a national
backlash
that automatically makes him not only
the bad guy here but an a-hole of
gargantuan proportions
and the fact that he's doing all this to
some random low-paid service industry
workers only makes him even more of a
sociopath by the way I have at least
twice in my life okay I'll go on the
record
twice in my life at least I have been
approached by staff members at a hotel
and asked a similar question on one
occasion I was sitting in a hotel lobby
and I was asked whether I was a guest
and the answer was no because I was
actually just there to steal their Wi-Fi
to be honest on another occasion the
answer was was yes I was a guest and uh
and I was innocent of any crime on both
occasions I I simply answered the
question
that's it I wasn't interested in getting
into an argument with Hotel employees I
didn't see it as a publicity opportunity
and even though I was slightly
embarrassed on the first occasion when I
was essentially thrown out I had no
desire to exact a Vengeance or send an
angry mob after them
neither incident seemed you know
important or interesting to me which is
why I never mentioned them until just
now
it's true that hotel workers in my
experience normally won't ask you what
you're doing in the lobby but if you sit
in enough hotel lobbies you'll likely be
questioned at least once or twice in
your life
in Mark Curry's case considering how
shocked and offended he was we can
assume that this was the first time he'd
ever encountered this line of
questioning
so when he says oh black man can't go
anywhere well according to you you could
go anywhere you've never this is the
first time it's ever happened to you
which why you make us a big deal out of
it
which means in the anecdotal comparison
by the way I have had this experience
twice as many times as he has
the only difference is that I don't have
a reflexive racial filter to feed every
experience through
so if somebody says something to me
whatever it is
I don't immediately think hey he just
said that to a white man
I don't think that okay instead I think
hey he just said that to me
do you see the difference now I am of
course aware that I'm a white man I'm
happy to be a white man because that's
part of my identity I'm proud to be who
I am but I don't solely think of myself
as a faceless representative of a racial
category
when I walk about in in my life and I'm
operating and doing things I I don't
think I am a white man doing all of
these things
like I'm like I'm some sort of agent
some sort of PR rep for whiteness
and so if I perceive myself to be
treated unfairly in a given situation
I will not automatically assume that the
treatment was racially based I will
cycle through any number of potential
explanations first I'll wonder if the
individual just doesn't like me
personally
you gotta think about that first like
it's it's if you're people treating you
a certain way
uh maybe they just don't like you maybe
it's you that maybe you're the problem
or perhaps they're having a bad day or
perhaps they're simply incompetent or
perhaps uh you know perhaps you weren't
treated unfairly at all or perhaps any
number of other explanations and if
there is specific evidence that I was
the victim of racism then I'll take that
into consideration
I'm not going to rule it out
but of course it's not gonna be my first
assumption
it's not gonna be my first last and only
Theory because I'm aware that I am more
than a racial category and so is the
other person in the exchange and I'm
aware that life is complicated and
people are fueled by many different
kinds of motivations
but race Hustlers are conditioned or
have conditioned themselves
to see themselves
as nothing more than racial
representatives and to see everyone else
in the same light and to see every
interracial interaction as a contest
between those racial categories
that's why Mark Curry declared during
that exchange that a black man can't go
nowhere in America
because he sees himself as that a black
man just that just a black man not Mark
Curry okay not Mark Curry this isn't
happening to Mark Curry
they're doing this to Mark Curry he
didn't say that is this is simply a
black man just a generic black man
it's not Mark Curry being asked to
produce his room key it's a black man
being asked to produce his room key
that's how he sees it
or pretends to see it
because it is more profitable for him to
see life that way
indeed Mark Curry has not had much
success recently simply being Mark Curry
nobody cares much about Mark Curry or
wants to hear his lame stand of Comedy
but when he becomes a black man
generically that faceless representative
of a racial category
that's when he gets the attention he so
deeply craves
and that's what this is all about
and it's why Mark Curry
who happens to be a black man
is today canceled
and that'll do it for us for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]